I then chatted with him on
Twitter then at some point he said
let's switch to Signal somehow
then we chatted on Signal
at some point we
talked on the phone
and I thought it would be a 5
minute phone call, the guy is the
focus of one  worldwide scandal 5
6 7 million customers have no idea how
much that was, they're all mad at him.
He was extradited from the Bahamas
to the USA with a bail of 250
million dollars, a sum
that
blows your mind and he's sitting there with
his  Parents at home in California
basically in his children's room house in the house
with the ankle bracelet and
actually has everything else to do other than
chat with the German journalist somehow and at some point
he asked me when I was there
on the west coast
You have a few interviews and you think it's clear, come
over, welcome, thank you very much, hi
Phip, you've been here for
a few years now, you can say that
we've also been a game at
the previous school and then now when did
you go to the Sam
Backman freed  Yes, for
me it started relatively early.
I got involved with crypto for a few years and
then I kind of
went into a rabbit hole like many others during a pandemic and I'm always
a bit over FTX
Sman Freed's stock market stumbled as a
name but actually it only
became clear to me who he was when there was
this huge crash last year.
When exactly was that in the USA from 2017
to 2019 but back then it was
n't a big issue  FTX so no
household name so it wasn't a
household
name but crypto was already such an issue
because the Bitcoin price was always rising
FTX only came onto the
scene around 219 220 sometime a little
later yes D clear at some point
they even have them like that  Superbowl switched on
and so yeah, it was crazy, they were
really so huge. Super Bowl ADS
somehow bought a basketball stadium in
Miami, they spent so much money
that was really unbelievable in the USA,
so you have to go back a bit to
the time of the pandemic as crypto  It
was huge, that's how it was for me, by the way,
I heard about FTX for the first time about
ten years ago and everyone was talking
about the founder of it, Sam bman freed, who
is also abbreviated as SBF, who is
today, what is he today, who is 31 today
and  There's of course a reason why you're
so busy with it now, so
no book but a podcast series,
maybe a book, but they're
doing a lot of things right now, so he's
the really big name, especially in the tech industry,
absolutely, so
he's a huge name  because it
was all a huge crash and that's exactly what
our podcast series is about and
that
was one of the richest people in the world, but forbs
somehow put him on the list of the 400
richest Americans  an
estimated fortune of 26 billion
dollars at the end of 20, so you have to get that
sorted first and a bit to
classify it, I think the richest
are around 100 billion dollars, Elen
and Jeff bises and so on but so that's
already Germany would be very,
very far  He would probably have been
one of the richest Germans, but you
have to
have 526 billion by the end of your 20s. It was
just a paper asset, no, so this
rating comes from the fact that he
also had a lot of crypto tokens and who
knows how much money he was really worth
Tell me a little bit about his
career because I mean, before we
get to the whole crash and the
accusations that are now being made
and the whole bizarre development, there
are some funny twists, but how
did we get there? It's a very
interesting story  because Sam bman
freed was born in Stanford at the
university his parents were law professors
are law professors still that
means from a very very well respected family
on the US West Coast then there
was then there at the high school was such
a mat  Genie had already organized
some scavenger hunts at school,
was incredibly interested
in numbers, had an incredible talent
for calculations and was
very, very quick in his head. In the past,
we can perhaps
talk about it again. He
had problems with psychological problems in some way
Sleep disorder was also
somehow treated later and
then M somehow got promoted and
then had a place to study on the east coast,
i.e. the top university, top university, one of
the elite universities in the USA and was then
bought straight away by one of a
Wall Street trading company and  That's where he
learned his trade, that is,
he somehow understood
as a trader
how what it was all about, about
speed, about speed and
then he somehow said yes, Wall
Street is great, he made really good money
in his early 20s, but that's it
not my thing
and then he kind of said well there are
two options for me
either I'll go
do a charity like that
volunteer for an organization
or I'll start my own thing and uh
back then crypto was relatively big the
Bitcoin kururs  was slowly moving
towards this $20,000 mark and
then he said I was setting up a
trading company, what did he do so
the Bitcoin party was
actually quite late,
but I mean all the Bitcoin
millionaires, they are a lot
got involved earlier, which means there was
n't that now, so he
recognized the issue incredibly early,
you can't say, no, he wasn't a
crypto pioneer, he wasn't a
crypto activist either, he wasn't one of those
hackers who somehow said
with Bitcoin  I want to change the world with crypto,
so when he
came into the crypto space in 2017,
it was around that time. Bitcoin was already
8 years old
and he came into this industry
as a late entrant and
had this  So FTX founded
this in America today they say casino
but back then it was called
bank you can also see how the
terms change but when people
talk about it today it's different than it was
back then but it's unique and above all it has some of
the best investors
in the world so those who have the highest reputation
can
convince you to get into their thing, you just have to
imagine this space back then like
a gathering of really weird
characters like a gambler, a gambler, a trader
like a Wild Westing like a
yes  a casino like that and he came in there son
of neuror professors on the
west coast mate genius here and he was
suddenly the one that
everyone looked up to, he was the
serious one but also the one who said
from the start I don't want to be here at all
Make billions and
buy them and I want to do
good with the money and he has a
totally unique selling point plus
his exchange FTX, which was founded around 2019,
was really, really good, the product was
great at the beginning, the traders, from a technical point of
view, the traders  thought it was great, it
was quicker than others, it was easier to
handle, he then had a good
product that he brought onto the market and
then he also had
this fundraising, so he got a lot of
money completely legally from
investors who had shares  in the
company and then spent this money
to do extensive marketing
and that was to buy some kind of
naming rights to a stadium and
then gave lectures somewhere next to
him, say Tony Blair, all that kind of stuff,
absolutely what he
did was clever  He built a product
that a lot of people thought was somehow good,
he brought in the people, the
big funds from Silicon Valley, the
big names and that was,
let's say, half the battle. Everyone who
came after said wait a minute
when Sam bankman freed  He has the big names
from Silicon Valley on his side who are
investing hundreds of millions in his company, they have already
checked this
business model, they know the numbers,
they have done their due diligence and
that was probably the downfall
for many in the end  Investors are
also celebrities who were there with it,
so I think Tom Brady somehow
invested with it and then somehow
his Super Bowl ADS appeared, so
it was really, it seemed really
big and I have various friends
who are very successful themselves
who have a little bit of money  had left who
told me wow if they
could invest somewhere then they would
prefer to invest in FTX that looked from the
outside that had all the signals of success
and correctness
and it was actually
quite sensible as kngeschfs and absolutely so
the big names were  From the
investor side, the advertising was
very, very good in the
Super Bowl advertising in
a variety of participation in
stadiums and so on, so the name FTX
was somehow big, at least in the USA,
and at some point Bankman Freed
also started
to see I have to deal with big names
with with big people somehow
m to get in touch with to
somehow become known so you
just said it ne Tony Blair with Tony
Blair was on stage with Bill Clinton
Giselle Bünchen was somehow there her
husband at the time Tom Brady football star
was there then came  this Super Bowl ad
with Larry
davidedi American comedian C
enthusiasm everyone knew everyone knew all
these characters and Sam bankman
freed was right in the middle of it Katy Perry
Orlando Blom so all these people with
all these people he somehow
ate an evening was at parties took
photos of himself  and at some point
a lot of people in the USA knew him because he
had a good story. A
guy with such huge curls of hair
always walks around in shorts and so on and
some kind of slippers and was
also very, very approachable  For the
public, no, he's now
somehow you obviously
got access, but back then a lot of
crypto magazines, if you wanted to talk to him,
he was somehow available, and we
were even somehow
connected to the OMR Festival, so there was
someone even though he was at the top
you could get it, it was totally
accessible, um, it also kind of
tried to become its own brand,
a bit like Steve Jobs
with his turtleneck sweater, you know,
he was just the guy with the black
curls, um, shorts, T-shirt and
Somehow D ended up on
stage and you somehow thought,
yes, this guy is somehow
authentic and that was
probably a good
marketing idea from him, but you have to
say that the business model he had back then
It was done in the Bahamas,
so it was forbidden in the USA, that
would have been surprising, okay,
the power here has gotten rich with it,
which is not allowed in the USA,
so so far, so good, but still,
it was in itself, yes  also very clean so
it's the idea is actually he
has a stock exchange or a
casino whatever and they
trade around with coins and cryptocurrencies and he
somehow gets a commission for every transaction,
that's it  First of
all, it's not a problem at all,
it's not allowed in the USA because of the coins,
but it's understandable from a business point of view
and
you don't have to say where the money comes from. I
think that's crazy stuff, absolutely, so
he already had an exchange in  In the USA,
he was only allowed to offer a spot market,
so he was allowed to
buy and sell Bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies,
which means he also had
an exchange in the USA,
but he made the real money in the
Bahamas, where the
international stock exchange was located  ftxcom and
he offered exactly what you mean by
casino, um
derivatives, all these
complicated crypto um
things that you're actually
not allowed to do in the USA if you
're not regulated as an
investment bank and that was the big
problem for  He couldn't make a lot of money in the USA
with this spot market in
the Bahamas with
all these complicated financial products,
he earned millions and millions
and that was exactly the difference
between the US business and the
international business  in
the Bahamas okay okay that means but
this superb advertising was also made
for the international business yes for so
especially for the American for the
American market bman freed did
n't just want to make money he also wanted to
somehow influence politics in the USA
he came from  Because of his very
political parents, he also
did all these marketing measures
because he wanted to be known somehow
because everyone else
did it too except for him, all
crypto exchanges already had an
incredible footprint in the USA coinbase
crypto.com and so on  and he
just wanted to somehow get into this market
of notoriety,
so to speak, for a relatively large amount of money,
made donations to parties and SAS everything, it's
totally crazy how much money he
put into this election campaign before the
2022 congressional election campaign until then he has
about  He donated around 100 million dollars
to politicians. He gave 10 to 11
million dollars to a single
representative in Oregon who
also lost this election campaign.
He told me when I met him
and asked why you
actually did that. He said yes
I think that was a mistake, I wouldn't
do it again 10 million dollars
11 million dollars all lost everything
but he just wanted to become a big
number in Washington so so
to speak that was the story
to ramp up again um
and the whole thing  The money he
spent there was, as it now
turns out in hindsight or is
now being investigated, not
just
profits that he personally had that
he could personally do whatever he
wanted, but it was company money and
possibly also money from his
investors  That's the really big issue: did
he possibly finance all of this
stuff not just from the
company's equity or
from the company's profits that belong to him,
which would have been okay somewhere,
but also from money that was
handed over to him  Investors
who thought the money was somehow being
invested seriously or supposedly where they wanted to, that is
currently being processed, but before we
come to this whole conclusion, maybe how did you get there, um,
I have a DM for you on Twitter
written oh really yes
okay sometime in January in yes in
November the
whole empire basically collapsed from him and I
waited a bit and
wrote him a message on Twitter and asked, say, is there
someone in your area who can be contacted
for an interview and
somehow he answered relatively quickly and said
yes, ask our head of Europe,
he is definitely approachable, he
sent me an email and that's how we got
in touch, okay, okay
and that was the
first contact for you  the whole empire in
exactly W later met the parents
and something like that exactly so
I chatted with him on
Twitter then at some point he said
let's switch to Signal somehow
then we chatted on Signal
at some point we
talked on the phone m and  I thought it
was going to be a 5 minute phone call.
The guy is at the center of a
worldwide scandal. 5 6 7 million
customers have no idea how much it was. They
are all angry with him. He was
extradited from the Bahamas to the
USA with a deposit of 250  Millions of
dollars is also a sum that
somehow
blows your mind and he's sitting there with
his parents at home in California in
his childhood room in the house
with an ankle bracelet and
actually has everything else to do other than
chat with the German journalist somehow  I
think the first phone call lasted
about an hour and a half, we
talked relatively extensively and then we
chatted again and again, talked on the phone
for hours and that's how this contact
state came about and Irann said, look
over and at some point he
asked, so let's say I'm there  on the
west coast ma a few interviews you have
time and then says so sure come over
and then B your parents' house you got to
know the parents so well I went in there um
from the house it said um um so
it wasn't that easy to
get in there  House, um, you have to
imagine it, it's like, um, Stanford University
campus professor's villa with a
swimming pool and so everyone knew the
address at the university, too. Some students
somehow came to the house at the peak of this
scandal
and somehow got
there  somehow, um,
looked around a bit, what can you
see? Paparazzi were kind of lurking in front of it,
um, and I got there at the
end of April. There were still a
bit of roadblocks there, but you
could kind of see that it
wasn't that easy
to get in there  There was
a security woman standing in front of it
with a metal detector like that,
I wasn't allowed to take cell phones in,
no computers, no electronic
devices, basically just a pad and pen and
then somehow I met his parents
and his dog was a
German Shepherd named
Sandor, okay and
so what's going on now  zto say your
perception, we're coming to talk about
how he fell and what
happened afterwards, but you
liked it, you liked it, you were very likeable, you were
very approachable, it was always
written about him that he had problems
with people, a
little bit like that  To build closeness so that he does
n't look you in the eyes and so he
was very n we sat
together in the living room for four hours talking
I was able to ask him all the questions
that were on my mind
lost billions his ex-girlfriend
who somehow turned against him
so  I basically asked everything
I wanted to ask, his answers were
a bit like, well, so evasive,
partly scales, um, partly, um, also, um, vague as far
as the allegations are
concerned, so the big problem he has
is, um, I think that's my
guess  knows that he
is in quite a mess, that
a lot of things didn't go the way they should have
at his company and he can't
go into it that deeply without
saying at some point that it can't work anymore. I'm putting the burden on
myself here, that was  So his dilemma,
that is, I could somehow ask him everything,
his dog was
lying there on the carpet
and he was very approachable. You have to
say that even during his
rise, a little bit of PR
was his big strength  No, he was
viewed incredibly positively in the press back then,
perhaps wrongly
or probably so wrongly, but
because of his accessibility and
his unusual personality and
also the story that he actually only wants to earn all the
money he earns
for the D
to donate everything again, he has a certain
donation strategy or a new
donation concept that the supporter used was
effective altruism, i.e. he
had already had a lot of success with PR and
probably even now in
decline thought that's what I'm doing, I
talk a lot  Let everyone have a go then
the press will work for me again. Everyone
has him. Everyone
has always advised against
talking to journalists. His lawyers, his
press spokesman. Basically everyone
around him was against him
somehow calling journalists and
inviting them to his house  He then
said I became successful because
I did everything differently than what
people were advising me from
the outside, that is,
I am successful, I only rose to the top
because I completely
broke all the rules and somehow he got that
continued and yes, I
think it did him a lot of damage, you have to be
honest,
he was out on bail
and then gave the New York Times,
as his lawyers also admitted,
a lot of material, including
the diaries of his ex  -Girlfriend
leaked and that's why he was
taken into custody so
his strategy wasn't really successful
but yes you're absolutely right um he he
was open he was accessible he wanted he
actually wanted to tell the world
how he got into it like
all of that  What happened was at the beginning, he
wrote to me at the very beginning in our
first Twitter, um, um, messages. I
checked it again beforehand. I
asked him. Say, won't it do you any
total harm if you talk to me now,
why are you talking, why are you giving an interview
afterwards  that everything collapsed and he
said well
the truth will come out at some point, there
will be a few false things
said about me and I have the
choice either I'll be quiet and let it
all wash over me, let this whole wave
run over me including this one
false claim or I've been
there from the beginning and can that
influence this story a little bit, this narrative a little bit, that was his hope
by talking to journalists by
talking to a German journalist from Spiegel at some point, I will contribute to that
partly my version of the story
somehow comes into the world, so
my interpretation now would be like
he had a lot of success in his peak phase,
I was my PR, he was
really positive, also
because of this altruism,
maybe you can get some of that  A few words to say
that effective altruism is also
a new thing in the tech scene somewhere
that many people are talking about, he also
pushed it very, very strongly, yes,
this idea of ​​EFF altruism is not new,
it has been around for a few years
but in Silicon  Valley there are more and
more followers so basically the
idea
behind it is I earn money I earn
a lot of money and donate a lot of it so 50
60 70% of my income and the more I
earn the more I can donate so
it's good if I earn a lot of money
Basically, it's a bit of an
idea that
has spread in Silicon Valley because it allows you to
morally justify your ambition in a career, um, and um,
and um, Sam came into
contact with this idea relatively early on
Um, a
thought leader from Oxford was at
lunch and said, Um, if you
donate 80% of your income, then
you can do a lot of good and
I talked to him about that too. I
asked him what his
favorite projects were. He could
n't really do it anyway  say something specific
and then at some point after
I asked a few times, he said
well, for example, you can buy mosquito nets for Africa,
so with the mosquito net you can save a
lot of people for very little money,
save a lot of lives, um, you
somehow protect
people  from somehow malaria fever
and so on and that's what he was all about
with possible idea of ​​Effek as I
understand it, you can't
say now I'm doing a
charity here for, say, neglected
children in Hamburg or something that might
be so obvious  You also
somehow like the
Sportvin around the corner or something like that and that
but you just do something which is
rationally very very well multiplied
so how do you say you buy mosquito in
Africa my example what I always know
is in the you have some worm cures in
Africa  then be financed because
then they can go to school more and do
n't have these stomach aches, that's a
big problem and then with
little money these worm cures
lead to a lot of positive things because then there are a lot more
school days and then a lot more
productivity, so it really pays off
logically through where the one
donation dollar supposedly brings the most,
that's the principle it's about, it's
about exactly this principle of
effectiveness where my money is
used most effectively and it's all
about scalability so the more scalable the
better and that's interesting
just that these Silicon Valley people have
tried
to disrupt charity in such a way, to
somehow say where is the best place for my dollar
and with this
justification you can basically
do anything, you can basically
justify anything, you can
justify any business model if you
say so  I have to earn so much money
because I donate so much and then
I can save as many lives as possible, so that's what it's all about, so that's what
brought him up somewhere, so
this whole sheer personality, this
approach, there's a 29-year-old guy who's so
rich that he wants to  but in the end,
he doesn't have the money for himself, he always
just shows up with empty clothes and he doesn't
think he has any luxury items
or anything like that, so that was all
good for a long time and surprisingly
the police
or any investors haven't brought it down yet  but its
competitor from the crypto exchange
binance you might know
a bit in the OMR context, he was also
with us at the
CC Shang Peng jao festival last year or something like that,
but his real name is CZ,
so CC er is at least called it and that  Um, it
was always a competitor
of FTX, of course, they were both
kind of fighting for the same customers
and money and then he
somehow came up with a few tricks
to bring the freed down all of a sudden,
there was a little
history  I want to
tell you that again um well um it didn't come
out of the blue like that uh 2022
last year um uh it's also a
bit related to the war in Ukraine
this the interest rates
rose the cheap money slowly disappeared
from the crypto market people
were buying  more like gold than any
coins tokens digital currencies
m and
a lot of companies stumbled
in this space bankman freed had
a stake in a lot of a lot of
crypto companies m at some point hgefs started to
go rotten to
go bankrupt in this cryptospace
this hgef from  Bankman Freed slipped
into the deep red numbers and
at some point he noticed that I was really having
a massive problem, then tried to
counteract it, tried to
somehow put new money into it
and sometime at the beginning of
November last year there was a message
on an industry website
that said  the hgefor from bankman fre
is deep in the red and no longer
has any collateral that
was in any way resilient, so an
investment bank that is really
starting to burn where there
is a fire and she
saw that she said somehow  I see
the problem too and then I
said publicly on Twitter that we can
imagine taking over this company from Bankman
Freed and
that kind of triggered
panic for a lot of people
Competition to damage once again
really poured oil into
this little fire, so to speak, and then it got
really big. At the beginning, Hal
said, yes, we'll take care of it,
maybe after a few days, he
then said, we looked at the numbers, but it does
n't look like that  rosy,
you can of course ask yourself, was
n't it clean from the start, somehow his
big plan
to somehow harm this company, somehow
his biggest competitor, binance, was
the biggest crypto exchange at the time, FTX, so at times
the second largest, so his
biggest competitor, um, and then he
tweeted uh we're not taking it
uh we're not doing this
takeover uh and probably
we're selling all the FTT tokens so the tokens
from Sam bankman freed that was the
death knell for bankman freed then
this big bank run started everyone wants to race to the
ATM
clear out their accounts and
then somehow an avalanche started,
someone
played hardcore in public in order to publicly discredit his competitor, so to
speak,
so that
all of his customers thought okay, that
's all here now, I have to
get my money quickly and that's it  The model was
absolutely broken by him, so he
eliminated his biggest competitor, you just have to say it so harshly that
the bank run started with a billion
a day, 2 billion flowed from
this exchange, such crazy sums of money and
at some point
that only lasted a few  For a few days
the pressure on bankman freed became
so great that he said okay, the
whole thing no longer makes sense and that
now leads to the question that
has now been resolved to this day
[music]
were there even enough funds to
serve everyone  Then all of a
sudden they wanted to have the money or had
some of this money already been spent because that is, so
to speak, the reason why he
is currently in custody because he is
accused and that is of course in the USA or
worldwide if you are a
bank or  If you run a casino or whatever and
take the customer's money
and embezzle it, so to speak, then
you have a big problem - the fact
that the company doesn't fly is
n't worth a prison sentence, that
's it, that's a business
mishap, but the scandal is
that  Question and this is also unclear,
did he dip into the cash register and
use his investor money for
all of these spectacular donations and
investments that we were talking about? Yes,
absolutely, that is exactly the question, the
question is in the end it will be
possible to prove to him that he did so intentionally
and
consciously used his customers' funds
to speculate so
his investment arm the investment arm of
his crypto empire this hgefor
reached into the cash register of
customers so ultimately it looks like this
for the investigators and that's what
the public prosecutor's office also says as if  Because a
cashier at a bank said, dear
customers, I'll take your money, park it
with me, and then he somehow
went to speculate with it in the evening,
somehow used it in the evening to
speculate on crypto development and
then suddenly it was gone and this
cashier was next  The day when
the bank opens again then has to
say to its customers sorry, I've got it, I've
tried everything but unfortunately
your deposits have been lost, that's
the picture and that's also the
main accusation of the investigators that Sam
bankman fre his customer money,
investor money  used it to
speculate on the markets and
failed miserably, so
of course it's difficult to figure everything out
because so
much money probably flowed into the company anyway,
including from investors, which, as I said, is a
different type of investment in the company  Of
course, you can then
use it for marketing and so on, that
's
the company's equity versus the customers' investment money
and because both of them hundreds of millions have flowed into both,
so
it's very difficult to see what
happened and how  In
any case, there are a few interesting
stories: one is his girlfriend at the time,
who is also a young
woman at the end,
who also worked for his private
hedge fund Alameda research, who
worked as the boss, who has now also
become a key witness against him, but it  It
was somehow always
astonishing that such a young woman
suddenly had so much money running such a
hedchfund. The question was, did so
much money come from that H could already run it,
so even if you
looked at it back then, you thought it did
n't even exist  what it all means, they were
all somewhere between 20 and 30,
no one was there except maybe
a few lawyers or something who
were somehow over 30 and they
all came from Wall Street and they
all had a Z D year
Experience or something and just felt
like they were like kings you have to
imagine within 2 d or four
years
um you start a company
within 2 d 4 years you are a
multi-millionaire multi-billionaire
um and you think um I have here um
ultimately like so  Somehow an
alchemist in the Middle Ages somehow
found the recipe to somehow make gold out of
straw or something like that and they
had no doubts at all.
Caroline Allison, you just
spoke to her, Sam's ex-girlfriend,
um, somehow she had the job at this
trading company  He feels totally overwhelmed to take over,
so she
said that herself, she also saw Sam and he said to me,
I probably should have replaced them a little earlier,
but they were
all somehow latently
overwhelmed with this
business that they were doing  So there were and there
are also stories about how you were once in
the Bahamas where they lived,
yes, so there must be some luxury
property in the Bahamas where they
lived so beautifully there, with
multiple amorous relationships and
something else, yes, yes, so  Of course,
I saw this message too, I can't do it,
I can't really check
how they were related to each other,
but the Bahamas are
such a
luxury island anyway, um, and they do
n't have anywhere on the island  Bahamas
but in a luxury resort that Justin
Timberlake and Tiger Woods founded.
You can only get in if you
go through a barrier past security
and then they have another
one in a house where you
somehow go through one  You
had to have security at a marina like this,
they had a penthouse
on the top floor with a
view of the Caribbean and they
lived there. Bankmanfed bought 15
penthouses
with the money from this stock exchange,
about 140 150 million
bought wills and so on  And
then somehow they all lived together,
the inner circle worked, it was
basically their office and I worked there. I was there for
three four days,
looked at it,
talked to ex-employees, sat
around on the beach and got this
I looked at everything somehow,
this marina, they're all like, um, they
're all like that, yachts from
people who are kind of young,
then there are young people falling out
of such a huge boat at half o'clock at night,
completely drunk
[music],
laughing and that  The environment in which
they worked
was a rock stars, there were pop stars
Justin Timberlake and so on, he
also drove around there, so the fdx
employees saw that and they
felt like they were in the
Bahamas like these young kings
somehow  who somehow got into money
and now it's getting even more
spectacular because you see it as an
absolute anchor of solidity and
security, namely your parents, this
Stanford professor. Stanford is not just
any university and now you have to be a professor
and also for law and  I
think the father was even involved in the
whole financial market legislation in the USA. There are
stories like that, so
you always thought, well,
it can't be that bad because he comes from a
very sensible family and the parents
are not close, even in the end they are very young
But now there are
stories that the parents also
got some penthouses as
gifts from him or
something like that, so his parents,
his father, Joe Bankman, was a
consultant for FTX at some point and Sam
said come to the Bahamas and
there  He was able to buy everything he
wanted anyway, so he bought a villa for them
worth around 16 million,
a huge house that they used, that they
used, and
somehow gave them a cash gift of 10
million and that's all happening now
Legally, all of that
is somehow the subject of
all of these processes, not
criminal cases but civil law and
and they were there with him for a long time
in the Bahamas, these parents Joe
Bankman was in tax law or is
specialized in tax law so he
somehow knew his way around there too  in
this industry and then
somehow helped with the question of where
is it actually good for a
crypto exchange like this to locate
and the Bahamas were very practical
because the
crypto legislation was there. Crypto was
regulated but very,
very crypto-friendly  you have an
impression of the parents, I mean they
have actually experienced the crash,
they are also very
public, especially in Standford, and
we now have a huge
loss of reputation plus the fact that there are now
somehow accusations against them,
how do you perceive them?  Well,
they were very open, we had
dinner together at home. Joe
Bankman cooked somehow and Sam
is a vegan and only eats French fries,
potatoes, Brussels
sprouts and
mushrooms and so on. They were nice and
we talked about everything  Somehow they
talked about Trump, about Joe Biden,
about a war in Ukraine, then the
closer it got to the topic of FTX, the more
reserved they became. At some point,
his mother once told me, um, when I
asked how did you perceive these last few
months, this whole
process, the justice system meant  they, um, it's
like you woke up in a Kafka novel,
somehow, um, completely
chaotic, um, and they felt like they were under
siege by
this justice system, I think they
still feel like victims,
um, and um, all these
millions give away the fact  that her
son somehow
bought it or bought a villa, they did
n't want to
discuss it like that and it
only came out a few days ago
that there is this lawsuit or this
procedure against them from the
insolvency administrator  Company and what
is your personal impression?
I mean, there are several
lawsuits going on now, but if you
have researched it so intensively,
you believe that what is in the allegations is
that he used this money
and, above all, if it is like that  Was
it intentional or was it
just more like how he portrays it now
or like the
storyline is totally messed up, he
didn't have an overview anymore, he was a
bit
overwhelmed with the whole
situation, as you say, then
maybe accidentally  reached into the wrong cash register
but wasn't aware of it now, so
that's actually the question that
this process has to clarify and
in the end I really can't really
answer it was there was an intention
behind it, he knew that
customer money was used for this purpose
Speculating on crypto exchanges is the fact
and it is also relatively clear that there are
very, very clear indications that
the investment company run by him, this his
ex-girlfriend, back then Alameda
research this Alameda research that
they had an unlimited credit limit
for this for this exchange that
means  They were able to accumulate up to 65 billion
dollars in debt on this exchange
and the fact that they slipped into the red
and at some point,
as it looks like,
customer money was probably used to
plug this huge hole. I think that's
for the investigators  It is relatively easy
to prove that there are a few
lines in the code of this
crypto exchange that have also become public
where you can see that they
simply had almost unlimited
credit limits, so the process we have to
clarify is
whether Sam bankman freed very much  knew about it very early on
and when he knew that there was
this mixing, that the
customer's money was used for this purpose,
this process will now have to show that
the problem for him is that not only
his ex-girlfriend is a fundamental
indictment, but also three other
top managers from the company  Those
on the prosecution side became key witnesses for
the prosecution, that's just
incredibly difficult for him and everyone
says everyone also admitted Sam made
us do it, made us do it,
ultimately told us
what we had to do and made us do
exactly that  to do what we were
accused of, namely
using these customer funds, that's
blatant. If you had
n't had this fund on the side at all, if you had
just had the
core business mellfol then it would
still be worth billions or at least
a very, very valuable company
You can really make money with it,
I already said it at the beginning,
so it's simply unnecessary, it's
not like with a wrecard
or where the business is simply not that
big or in other cases or with
such delivery models, it's okay  can you
really make money with this delivery
and so that's all there
because you had a large stock market and
would have just had to pay normal taxes
and he would still be very very
wealthy absolutely absolutely so I
you
asked you asked was the intention  Was it
somehow a mistake or was he just
overwhelmed? I think all of that is true.
There was a mix of
motives. There was also an element of
excessive demands. He was somehow able to
lose track of things, but I
believe that the prosecution is paying very close attention
to it  is to
prove when from this when he
learned when he understood
how dramatic the situation in his
company was and somehow
the cash register was reached,
the whole thing is
not only accompanied by you in a journalistic way
but there is  a lot of interest in
one of the most famous authors,
economics authors at least in the
USA, Michael Lewis,
he's right in the middle of it all.
So Michael Lewis, you have to say,
perhaps had the luck of something
that every reporter wishes for, namely, um,
he was there from the start  somehow um
probably by coincidence
um in the innermost core of this
company and long months before
this collapse occurred he
spoke to bankman freed he spoke to the
parents he spoke to everyone
around him when there were
any signs of it  knew that there
could be problems and
was invited to his parents' house, came
and went there.
Michael Lewis was the man with whom
bankman freed
talked for hundreds of hours, who was like
his own biographer, in a way,
at the end, at the
end  It was the same and his book will be
published next week. I do
n't want to advertise myis' book here,
but I do
n't think anyone was closer to it than him, so
Apple already bought the rights. I think
Apple TV bought it for 5 million
Bought the book rights from Michael Lewis
so he doesn't have to worry about anything
financially. It was
one of the biggest researches in
Dechen's life, absolutely, so it
was a very long research,
very intensive, so I wouldn't have
thought that at some point  The
multi-billionaire ex-multi-billionaire
from such a huge crypto exchange simply
says so yes, come over
and
it was a very, very long
research, it started in January, I
drove to the USA several times to the
west coast, was at the bar and
talked to his family  with himself,
with friends, childhood friends, with
ex-employees, we were a big team,
so it wasn't just me alone,
but also my colleague Regina
Steffens
Marcel Rosenbach, many others who
did the research, so it was really quite a
large team with
us in the end  yes, they are trying to
work through and reconstruct this story
and did he know what or
who the mirror was, could it be closed or
was it just like that?
Yes, he comes from a relatively well-educated
family. They already know people on the coast of the
USA know him  Spiegel already
actually knows the German
qualityism yes absolutely the
German news magazine,
they already know
something, so most of the things or
most of the articles are of course written by
the New York Times and that is logically
the more relevant medium for them, but
they also know Spiegel  Okay, that it was generally
decided resolutely. They
also give international journalists access
in order to somehow keep the image under
control worldwide. Philip, you imagine
it as an incredibly
well-
developed publication and
PR strategy. I think in the end S
is sitting there  a guy in his childhood room
uh uh uh uh in Stanford and
decides here someone writes to me
somehow on Twitter I
answer him and if he asks
can I come over then I say
somehow I know the person who is
on the phone and then I say come on
I think there's unfortunately
no real strategy and that's on
the one hand it makes him
authentic and somehow likeable
on the other hand he just takes
risks so um he
ended up in prison in prison again
because he  to the New York Times,
his lawyers admitted everything,
gave him diary excerpts from his ex-girlfriend, he thought there
was probably no one who
said Sam better leave it alone, there was
n't a huge strategy behind it, he
was taken out of house arrest and
then really e  He was imprisoned
precisely because of
this incident and is now in prison
because there were things in it that
incriminate him. The judge said no, no, the
judge said, um, you
admittedly have the diary excerpts from
your ex-girlfriend here, which is
an important
witness  in this case it has
been released to the press and we believe that you
want to intimidate this witness,
that's why you're going to jail, that's why
you're going to prison and that's why he's
now in
custody in Brooklyn to this day. His parents are allowed to visit him once a
week  his lawyers H fig he
's kind of bread water and
peanut butter because there's no vegan
food because there's no vegan food in prison,
the diet isn't as nice
as it is at home with mom and dad,
but that was the reason why he ended up
in  If he's
found guilty now, how many years in prison does it
say?
So there are seven charges, somehow each point has something like 20
years in prison, maybe a
little less, those are
the maximum sentences and if you add it all
up  as it is sometimes done in the USA
and he is found guilty on all charges,
he can go to prison for up to 100
years,
you can't say now whether that is
at all likely, but
the maximum sentence would be around 1000
years and so what  If you hear something like
that, it's conceivable that in the end a jury of 12
jurors will decide on each
individual charge, whether they think he's
guilty or not, then a
judge will decide
the sentence
again at the end a jury will
decide it will be a
mammoth trial it will be a huge
trial with experts over
many, many days so there will also be a
battle of materials in this
trial and in the end the
jury will have to say on every single point what they say
convinces me  The prosecution
says the public prosecutor's office or
I think it's more like bankman
freed will say or argue
that he was overwhelmed, that everything
was somehow a big mistake and that
he somehow also had
a risk management that wasn't there
in his company and that he simply
was overwhelmed, they believe him that way
and that a jury will then decide in the end
and then, as I said, a
judge will determine the sentence, but I
wouldn't go so far as to
say that someone is now threatened with 100
years in prison or something like that, but could be 10 to 20 years
It's easy to be precise, so
the risk is that if you
have a prison sentence of over 10 years in the USA,
you'll end up in a federal prison and
the prison conditions there are much, much
tougher than if you were in
that uh than if you were  less uh uh uh
than if you are in prison for fewer years
and then maybe uh a
bit uh somehow
have a more relaxed everyday life in prison, let's say anything over 10 years becomes
relatively critical so you're stuck
with some murderers and
drug dealers  Prison he now says yes,
I think he only has $50,000 left in
the account only in quotation marks
but maybe before that it's
significantly less and then he makes
such public statements is that
credible that's a good question I
know on  In the end, not how much, so I do
n't think he has a lot of money because
the US judiciary is very specific about it,
oh
where do you have an account, what's on it, it
will also be difficult
to park money somewhere
abroad, so I think he does
now really let's say for him
for so if you have 26 billion
at some point it's on paper and
only have 100,000 then you
actually have zero
so and that that that's already
believable how much how much money his
parents have no idea
[music  ] um but
that's also running out quickly somehow,
they
bought the chefround because at some point the
security became too expensive um and
then they somehow wanted this chef dog um I
somehow bought it for $20,000 the
security somehow cost twice as much
a week and  Um, and then they
said, it's going to be too expensive for us,
so you have to imagine these
lawyers that are employing them, it's going to
cost um 100 thousand or somehow millions, it's all really, really
expensive and now the lawyers are doing it
in the hope that  the parents
will pay one day or yes, of course,
somehow they will get their bill
paid, okay, and does he have
siblings, he has a younger brother
who also plays a role in the process
because he helped Sam to
somehow gain a foothold in Washington
Washington worked on Gabe Backman
and wanted to use millions to prevent the
pandemic. He
also benefited from his brother's crypto empire
and was also very heavily criticized. He
is not directly involved in this
process, but there were also
demands  give him
to pay back money okay okay al yes for the
family also just crazy in my
highest circles now the
crash is so absolute it's a very very
it was a very very high rise and
an incredibly deep fall and you
spoke to him for the last time  That was
actually in April when I was with him
um and um the last time
I was at his house was
3i weeks ago and I spoke to his father for an
hour and a half,
went for a walk with him and um I had um yes I had
with him  talked to him,
also talked to friends, a
family friend of his, who also
knew Sam as a child, said he's really
afraid, um, that Sam will
somehow break down mentally if
he goes to prison for a long time,
you still believe that after all that  to this
cryptocurrency to this development h that
fundamentally changes things for you
did you ever believe in it yes so
what does it mean to believe in it so I
always somehow liked the approach
of a few young people who
somehow sit together and somehow do
this very old and  fix and
sometimes also
dangerous financial system to somehow
challenge this
I like this impulse
in this crypto industry who
somehow said let's
build or at least
try to build a system that avoids all these
mistakes that led to
us  In 2008 we got into a crazy financial crisis
and slipped. I
then
tried things out a bit and
somehow bought a bit of cryptocurrency myself. I have
no idea 5
years ago or
so not much so not at all not
big but I've got it somehow  When I
tried it out, this industry became
increasingly unappealing during the research.
I have to say because you
just because it attracts so many people
who are just like gamblers. All these
influencers who try to
somehow bring in a mass audience
Millions of
people who are
brought into this
crypto scene who don't have any
real experience with such
complicated financial products and
they think if I somehow
buy 0.01 Bitcoin now I'll be a multimillionaire the day after tomorrow
and they're just going to
be there  somehow
brought into this scene and
then hope that they will somehow
drive in Lamborghini next year and
I find that very, very critical and
benefit from this,
this industry benefits from
this gear from the longing of
millions of people somehow
to become rich overnight and I found that,
I also found that with sankman freed, so
in the end he said yes, I would give
part or a large part of my
income to charity in some way, but in the
end he also
lived from the fact that there are these huge influencers
with somehow millions of followers
who bring these millions of people into
this into this into this industry
that is almost not regulated at all um who
sells um financial products where you
actually need an exam in normal finance
as a trader before you
can get in there and um that
I think that's um
so very, very worth considering and
worrying me there are also
different categories bitcoin is
still relatively stable 30,000 or
something like that, so despite all
the escapades and and and and and topics there
are of course a lot of other coins
are completely at zero and and and have
become worthless so it's time to
take a look, maybe in the end
there will be two currencies
coming through and some or most of them are
not clear, so bitcoin is
a network that has been around
since 2008 2009  It's been
running relatively stable for a decade and a half, you have to
say no,
it's a super volatile
[music]
category of values, no
asset,
you have to know that before you
go in. Bitcoin has fallen from its high of
2 years ago to about $69,000, I don't know
to something like 25,30,000 it
somehow goes up and down
many other digital currencies have
also crashed somehow even more
dramatically it's somehow almost at
zero maybe it'll go
up again at some point I don't know I don't know
everyone in these uh in Bitcoin
and other currencies  If
I invest in digital currency, I have to
be aware that it
can go down relatively hard again, and I do
n't know if there are a lot of people
who park their money there, so I mean,
the SAMP doesn't have a few really good
investments  I think
Robin Hood did this, um yes, they say a
kind of American version of Trade
Republic, a neobank invests
between 10% of it
and over 20 billion, the BSE went to the
marketc, so company registration, so
he also has a good hand there
He had expanded and
made investments in related industries with any money wherever it came from.
You invested in everything and Robin
Hood somehow invested, I don't know,
5,600 million, which
also shows how much money he has
He somehow invested 100
million in or I think
half a billion in an AI startup,
he threw money around, he
somehow invested in vertical farming, i.e.
organic farms, and he
also somehow invested in drone
manufacturers and military drones  He
put money into the
fertility clinic, basically he
invested in everything that wasn't up to
three. You
have to ask yourself where so much money comes from, but it
should actually
be understandable because
it's only possible for him to get money legally  It would have been possible
through the profits from FTX,
which are then distributed, so to speak,
and then his share of it, that would be
a way to get money legally or to
make sales of FTX shares so secondaries to investors that
somehow a squire or something like that comes says
okay, I give  Otherwise there is no way for me to give you money for the shares or to
buy money privately, so to speak, so that
you can speculate and make a profit. These are perhaps the only three ways in which you
can really get large sums of money, but when I
look at it now  On the outside,
of course, a very rough gut feeling. Only
then is it difficult to generate as
much money as
has just flowed out left and right in one of these
three ways, no, absolutely,
so
in the end I think he
somehow really has it with both hands
Money was thrown out, um, and in fact
his participation and investments were significantly higher in terms
of the amounts than there is somehow
a pantas in the Bahamas, even if it
sounds a lot to us,
a quarter of a billion houses and
penthouses and offices in the
Bahamas  Also really a lot of money but
he somehow spent most of these billions
on investments
and that's exactly what you know
about FTX, it was a very highly
profitable company and they had
relatively high sales because
they offered such risky products
The percentage of him, the
fees were also relatively high, they
somehow had annual sales
of 100 million, somehow it was
in the billions, that was
profitable, which means then purely
theoretically he could at least be
able to earn a little bit of money from that, but
if you say a billion FTX sales
then the percent takes the FTX on it
and then his share and then
you would have had to make the payment first and
then
tax it, so it's unlikely that there would
be so much money for him so quickly, of course he was also
somehow constantly looking for money,
he also has it  constantly looking for donors ne
he was with
[music]
a man named Anthony scaramucci who
was once became known
Keyword the M PRF by prchef
Trump's head of communications was
thrown out for 11 days and bmanfed said at some point
because skaramucci had good contacts
that's how the connection came about  to Tony
Blair Bill Clinton and other celebrities
I want to buy part of your company,
your event business
rather scaremuci and that's how they
somehow got into business and at some point
they flew together to the Middle East,
i.e. Saudi Arabia, among
other things, to look for donors but
then also there  then he would have had to sell shares in
FTX in order to
legally obtain larger sums privately,
yes, pay attention, the trick was that he did
n't sell Ex but rather built his
own
currency, namely FTT, this
token and
like one of his own  The head of the central bank
somehow said, I'm going to invent
my own money. You can
buy it somehow, you can invest it
and then you just buy parts of this
company without actually buying shares in
this company  I had
n't mentioned it at
all, not in order to get money because you
always think, so to speak, in the classic business administration profits
or just sales of shares, or
in case of
doubt, yes then the dip in the
cash register but there was a fourth way in
this case, namely here  A way, so
to speak, to release a coin that
you print yourself as the
owner of the platform of this coin,
your own currency, your own coin, which
somehow started in 2019 with a
valuation of one dollar per coin and
has reached a high phase, which has risen to 80,
that is  It was a multiplied increase in the
value of this coin that he
created out of nothing, which he
created out of thin air, so to speak.
He wasn't the only one. There are
somehow hundreds of thousands of such
coins, perhaps 10 or 20 in size BSE
Conveniently a
very large stock exchange C you just
mentioned, he also invented his own coin
BNB, which is also doing relatively well
at the moment and Sam
somehow invented this currency, this
coin, um as a result, as the
price of this coin rose, so did it
Valuation of his company At
times, FTX was worth more than
Deutsche Bank, you have to imagine that
this company, this
crypto exchange, was larger, was
valued at a higher value than
a financial institution that
somehow had real customers and
real investments  No,
they've
become very big in a very, very short time. In the end, it's
a
crazy story. When will the EU
Podcast come out? The first two episodes
will be released this Saturday, so the
date is because we're going to watch it now,
so we're talking on
September 25th and the Saturday accordingly
is then the 30th of the 30th that's exactly when it comes
first how many episodes in total there will be
five episodes
a week who will
appear every Saturday and
we will tell the big the big
drama of the sman freed and book
or Netflix or in the kind of book  There is
n't one yet, we're currently
busy finishing the episodes,
but there will be a
lot of reports about it on spiegel.de from us,
okay, so if you like podcasts and I
hope the conversation here was
somewhat okay, you're
welcome to  Note to the colleague about the
work, I'm excited myself, I haven't
heard from Christop Schuermann,
the Spiegel team, in the sense that yes, I never
listen to the podcast, no matter where,
thank you very much for being there, thank you, everything is clear,
ciao